Mark and I started researching legacy,
um,
back in 2012.
Um,
and part of the reason we did is that we saw a lot of brands and headlines like
you do see today,
um,
that were going out of business brands that have been around for a long time.
Um,
just this past few months we've seen toys,
a rust,
Gibson Guitars,
um,
today orchard supply hardware.
Blockbuster actually had a couple stores in Alaska still open that nobody knew
about but just closed.
And the question arose,
what is it about the current context,
the current market that's,
um,
that,
that these long standing brands that we thought would always be around,
are no longer here.
Um,
and we looked closer at culture and so that we live in a very short term world
right now.
People are looking for instant gratification.
They're looking for an overnight success.
Um,
we celebrate it in the media and when we looked at the brands that we're
actually building modern legacies,
we saw a different behaviors.
So that was actually the inspiration for this book.
Um,
will we going back and forth tonight tire today,
talking a bit about this,
the stories in the book and uh,
we'll leave some time at the end for questions about,
uh,
about the material as well.
But,
um,
I'll,
I'll turn it over to mark just to share some of the original inspiration for the
legacy lab,
which is where this all started.
Hi,
I'm mark.
I'm a very Canadian.
Uh,
my parents sent me here from Toronto and said,
I'm a,
you're a failed musician.
Um,
you seem to be filling it advertising.
Maybe you could write a book and make the family proud of you.
So the inspiration for this cause my parents kicked my ass to write a book.
Um,
in addition,
uh,
it has to be working on some business problems for two very iconic brands.
The Lexus and the Ritz Carlton and one was coming up on being 25 years old and
one was coming up on being 30 years old.
And they had a fundamentally different point of view on how they looked at their
age,
um,
their success,
where they've been,
where they were,
where they were going.
In the case of the Automotive Company,
they felt that 25 years it was too young to celebrate,
uh,
all their success.
They felt that if they said,
look how far we've come and only 25 years,
the brands like BMW and Mercedes would say when you get to be 80,
90 to a hundred years old,
that's the moment when you should celebrate.
But if you really want to remark upon 25 years,
um,
we'll just pat you on the back and say,
look how far you still have to go.
And the iconic hotel company,
so things in exactly the opposite way,
which was the age of 30.
They felt that a 30 year old Ritz Carlton was too old to celebrate that it was
far better to be the cosmopolitan,
which was brand new than the 30 year old Ritz Carlton.
And I found that fascinating because so many,
um,
uh,
startup companies and entrepreneurs would come into our organization and say,
how do you succeed like Lexus and Ritz Carlton in 25 and 30 years?
And yet these brands did not know how to make sense their own success.
Concurrently.
I work at an agency called team one.
We work on Lexus and Ritz Carlton.
And we were going through our own sort of identity crisis,
which is a,
we started in 1987 and I'm effectively still a modern agency,
but the world was transforming all around us as you know,
um,
uh,
social media companies were behaving like ad agencies and entertainment
companies were behaving like ad agencies and ad agencies were behaving like
media companies.
And what we used to take for granted as being certain was changing dramatically.
Um,
and then probably most importantly,
uh,
I was about to become a dad,
for the first time in my life,
which was incredibly scary because I could barely take care of myself.
So now I'd be having to take care of another life.
And I was concerned that,
um,
the example I wanted to set for my daughter wasn't just that I've worked very
hard but to no end in specific,
but that I've worked very hard toward an end that was meaningful and important
to me.
And for that reason,
I started looking at leaders of organizations that we're building careers and
building brands that had stories that I had admired,
many of which we cover in the book,
but they weren't the ones who were simply doing things to make the greatest
amount of money,
but the ones doing things to make the greatest amount of contribution.
So those were the ingredients that really inspired me to start researching this
topic.
And then I reached out to friends and colleagues and peers,
including Lucas,
who had a wonderful career as a writer and a researcher with fast company.
And,
uh,
I was hoping he shared a little bit about,
um,
other than I bothered him to do it.
Why he bothered to help.
Yeah.
So,
um,
mark had been collaborating for over a decade and I started my career back in
2002 at the Atlantic monthly.
Um,
and that's a magazine that really invests in,
in long stories.
Um,
while I was there,
they actually published the longest story that they've ever published,
which was three cover issues in a row that I'm the one in national magazine word
that you're on the unbuilding of the World Trade Center back.
Um,
2001.
And uh,
so I came out of that space in journalism of,
of really investing in stories,
really telling what,
what uh,
what was behind what the mainstream media or the standard media would tell in a,
in a,
in a journalistic approach to a story to,
to going on to fast company.
Fast company was a publication that was all about telling personal stories in a
business world and really getting into the leaders behind the brands.
Um,
whereas a fortune or Forbes might talk about the numbers or the products more
fast company was really interested in the culture and the people that built
those brands.
So when mark started describing a project about legacy,
uh,
my ears perked up.
I knew that was something that really resonated with readers.
And when I actually got on the ground working with some of the interviews,
I was hearing things that I rarely ever heard in,
in journalism.
Um,
people would describe for us a variety of stories throughout their life and at
the end of the interview say,
Hey,
can I get a transcript of this?
I've never talked about a lot of this stuff.
Um,
and these were CEOs who've been interviewed countless times throughout their
career.
So I knew that we were asking about something that was very important.
Um,
whether you asked somebody young or old about legacy,
they have some very personal,
meaningful things to share about the way they see their life,
the way they see meaning and significance.
Um,
so it was a very rich topic to invest our time in.
and uh,
well what was,
what was interesting from there is that it wasn't just our personal interest.
I mean we,
we started to see that there were leaders who also wanted to share that share
that,
um,
the story of their legacy.
So what we thought we would do over the course of the next,
um,
15,
20 ish minutes is walk you through some of the key principles that we've learned
from the leaders that we spoke to.
Uh,
we'll topline the five key chapters,
the five key principles,
and tell you some iconic stories that we'd love to share.
Certainly at the end,
if you have questions,
we'd be happy to take them with they're easy questions.
We'd be even happier if their heart will probably say,
oh,
that's a really good question.
We'll get back to you.
And we may or may not.
Um,
so the first chapter in the book is about taking leadership personally.
And as a bit of an anecdote,
I went to a business school and the reason that matters is because I remember
talking to my parents distinctly at one point and said,
I'm thinking that,
um,
for higher education,
I may go to film school,
um,
or I may go to business school.
And they said,
well,
you should do whatever you want as long as you go to business school.
So I did that.
And one of the first lessons they taught a business school is what is the
responsibility of a business today to which the answer was maximize shareholder
revenue.
They never talked about taking leadership personally.
In fact,
they said leadership is organizational.
It's not personal and the only responsibility you have is to maximize
shareholder return revenue.
Um,
and yet the leaders that we spoke to speak beautifully and prolifically about
the things that drive them and seldom if ever did they begin conversations with.
I had an idea that I wanted to make $1 billion and sell my company.
They always began with a problem that they were trying to solve or a quality or
an attribute that they wanted to put into the world.
And the Tribeca Film Festival was a story that I happen to fall in love with.
As I said,
I grew up in Toronto.
The Toronto Film Festival was a major event and I was always curious to know in
a cluttered,
cloudy field of Sundance and con in Toronto,
how does a modern festival like Tribeca pop up and succeed to which the answer
from the founders of Tribeca Deniro and Rosenthal and Hatkoff was the world
didn't actually need another film festival.
And so if all we were creating was a film festival,
this would have failed and where's the world didn't need another film festival.
The world didn't need the Tribeca film festival.
And I'll share with you the story they shared with me.
The three of them grew up in and around New York.
They happen to love film.
They were people of means and people with tremendous influence.
Um,
who at one point toyed with the idea of introducing a film festival into New
York because that was their lifelong passion,
but they never really saw a hole in the conventional landscape.
It just didn't make sense.
And then nine 11 happened.
And here you have some people weren't just filmmakers but had a deep care and
consideration for the city that was home.
And they observed from where they sat as people with means and influence that if
people weren't going out and patronizing the businesses that were still around,
that not only when New York feel,
um,
devoid of life and vitality,
but as commerce would dwindle,
the city would get worse,
not better over time.
And so they went out to restaurants and they thought,
what if we could get more of our friends who also have influence in means to
come out with us?
And they created a program called dinner downtown.
This existed before the Tribeca film festival was ever born.
And all they did was they said,
um,
you my friend,
you should come to dinner and you should invite 10 of your friends and let's
keep doing the same thing.
And so they grew an event which they ran on more than one occasion where a
hundreds of people,
very influential people,
including Bill Clinton and a queen,
newer would come and patronize the restaurants.
And what they observed was,
if this is what we can do with small application,
could we somehow scale that to impact more of the city of New York?
They actually,
their language was,
they thought about contribution before they ever thought about extraction and
the contribution they want to make was more people in New York coming out,
patronizing,
consuming,
um,
adding vitality and culture.
And they simply used film the thing they knew really well as a galvanizing
mechanism to do it.
Um,
they made a lofty promise.
It was close to the end of the year and they basically said four months into
2002,
the Tribeca film festival would be born.
They lead with their hearts.
They lead with their passion.
They led with their ambition.
Um,
but they weren't fully mature thinkers.
They didn't actually think it all the way through in terms of how do we get
money for this thing?
How do we communicate this thing?
How do we make sure that not only are hundreds of friends,
no,
but thousands of people and more from around the world.
And it wasn't until very late in the game,
they were about to call a media conference and canceled their idea or suspended
for a while that they got an unanticipated phone call from American Express that
said,
we'd heard what you guys were doing,
and let us tell you that as citizens of New York and people who were impacted
tragically by the disaster of nine 11,
we have a passion and commitment to revitalizing the city too.
That transcends conventional commerce.
We want to help you make this festival real.
And one of the first questions that American Express asks the founders of
Tribeca is,
but we need to know your three and five year plan to which the answer was,
we don't have a three to five year plan and we don't even know how we're going
to raise $1 million to market this thing.
Um,
and so they collaborated and American Express had been their partner for a
number of years.
They built the program from the ground up.
Today,
it's far more than a film festival.
There are storytellers,
they're storytellers in film.
They're storytellers in literature.
They use high technology to advanced storytelling as well.
They're toying with the idea of taking film out of the name of the festival and
they see Tribeca as being much more of a cultural event and even though the city
to the casual onlooker looks healed in a sense,
um,
they don't ever imagine a scenario where New York will not need the assistance
and support of a program like Tribeca to bring more attention and community and
interest in the city.
They make a reasonable amount of money.
They have very healthy iconic partners,
automotive partners and so on.
And that put a good amount of capital into the program.
But each year they begin with what positive impact we want to have on the city
of New York.
And as a consequence,
everything falls out of that.
And I loved how we summed it up in the book,
which is to say there are people who take leadership person.
Then there are people who take work personally.
They don't talk about maximizing shareholder revenue.
They're looking at a higher order return,
which is personal satisfaction,
gratification,
cultural rejuvenation,
and more
so from longterm personal ambition,
which is the first chapter to behaving your beliefs,
which is the second chapter.
You have a,
um,
kind of the arc of you can have one person with a longterm personal ambition or
a dream,
but rarely do you see modern legacy builders who do it alone.
We see groups and teams that build around values and beliefs.
So the second chapters focuses on beliefs and values.
And traditionally what you see up in the business world today with a brand
managers or business managers is they're accustomed to saying one thing and
doing another.
Um,
fortunately,
we live in a more,
more and more transparent world.
Consumers are demanding that the brands that they purchased,
the brands they follow actually at,
you know,
have the same values that they do.
Um,
and,
and those are what we would call,
call modern legacy brands.
And one of those is,
um,
the Bluebird cafe.
Um,
Bluebird cafe in Nashville.
It's one of the most famous country music venues in the world.
Um,
uh,
like Tribeca,
it didn't start out.
Um,
uh,
with its modern realization.
It started out as just a,
just a restaurant,
had a lunch service and there was no music.
Um,
and it was 1982 and the founder,
Amy Kurland,
um,
had inherited a small amount of money from our grandmother,
decided to open this cafe.
And as the years went by,
she said,
you know,
I want to educate myself about how to run a business.
And she went to community college and took a variety of courses and the one that
really stuck to,
for her,
it was a marketing course where the instructed her do one thing really well.
And,
uh,
what she realized about her cafe is that she,
she let her boyfriend play at the,
at the cafe once he was in a band,
um,
they'd set up a small stage and she realized that people were really gravitating
towards the music.
So over time the lunch service was dropped.
They doubled the evening,
uh,
performances so that they'd have a performance for new new musicians as well as
musicians who were established.
And it really took off.
And she had to stick to that as the brand grew because she only had a hundred
seats in this place.
She could have taken it somewhere else into a bigger location and really
essentially sold out and made a lot more money with this.
But it would have destroyed this vision of this brand to she had where she had
created a listening space for artists who walked in off the street.
Um,
Garth Brooks got off a bus and actually got his first,
uh,
album signed at the Bluebird cafe.
Taylor swift launched her career.
Those are the kind of artists that come back,
even the,
with their fame and have these tiny performances in front of a hundred people at
this place.
So she,
over the years,
was able to maintain the sanctity basically of,
of this listing space.
Um,
and it's telling the motto of the Bluebird Cafe is sh like,
they basically create this space where they don't want people to speak while the
performers are performing.
Um,
so they'll have,
you know,
bachelor,
Bachelorette parties will call and say,
can we,
can we book a bunch of seats?
And they'll say,
yeah,
but you,
you can't talk.
You're allowed to come,
but you're not allowed to make any noise.
Um,
so they hold very true to this value.
and to the degree that when Amy Kurland look to retire in the past few years,
she decided rather than sell the brand for the most possible amount of money,
she would donate it to the Nashville songwriters association.
So she called up a former employee of the bluebird,
worked there and said,
hey,
listen,
I know that whoever takes this over it won't be able to protect it like you guys
could.
What if I just donate it to you and you continue it in the tradition that I set
up?
And they said,
we'll pay you a fair price for it.
And took it,
took it over.
And in fact,
I've even carried its fame forward while maintaining the culture that she built.
Um,
there was a show called Nashville that you may have heard of.
The bluebird is us essentially a character in that show.
Uh,
whenever they're looking to bring the drama down,
um,
they,
they have a performance in the bluebird.
Um,
and the bluebird now has performances.
I'm in London on a pretty regular basis.
They have performances in Sundance every year.
So the brand has grown organically.
Uh,
but it has stayed true to that core value that,
you know,
that belief in protecting this space where musicians can perform and be heard.
Not only famous musicians,
but people who are trying to start their careers.
Um,
so that,
that is the end of the second circle or second chapter of the book that builds
out from the longterm personal ambition.
You want to talk about the third?
Yeah.
So we begin with taking leadership personally and we move into this notion of
behaving your beliefs.
Uh,
the next section of the book gets into this idea of letting outsiders in and the
iconic story we'd like to share as a brand and a platform you may have heard of
called it gets better,
which was developed by Dan Savage.
And what's amazing about it is,
um,
by conventional standards,
it should never have worked because they never designed a program which was,
here's the inner workings.
These are consumers.
And here's what we control and here's what they take because we've packaged it
that way from the get go.
Their intention was to create an idea and unleash it upon the world.
And their language was to become very uncomfortable with the idea or rather to
become very comfortable with the idea of being uncomfortable.
Um,
they didn't care that people were going to take their idea to mess with it.
In fact,
that was their design.
So the famous story goes like this,
and in around 2010,
a young man named Billy Lucas was bullied at school for being different,
that the other kids perceived him to be queer.
And they bullied him to the point that he killed himself.
And not only was that a sort of horrific outcome and story,
but the same kids that bullied him went onto his Facebook page after he died and
continued to effectively bully him and assault him in of his family.
And that enraged.
I'm a journalist by the name of Dan savage that had a popular column called
savage love and he wrote an enraged post,
which is,
it's horrible that these young kids would make another boy or any young person
feel so badly for being different that they would want to kill themselves.
And a reader of the story wrote back and said,
I wish I knew Billy Lucas because I would have told you that it gets better.
That effectively as life moves on and you have the benefit of perspective and as
you get a,
an older sort of wiser point of view,
you'll realize that these are silly,
foolish kids.
I shouldn't have had this kind of impact on you.
And that language stuck with Dan and him and his partner,
Terry Miller,
um,
created a video.
And so they did something that was very modern at the time.
They use social tools that other programs and platforms we're ignoring to say,
we don't need to be censored.
We can just put out in the world what we think and their ideas.
They would record a video.
I'm suggesting what life would look like from the point of view of an adult with
wisdom.
And they were hoping that maybe they'd get 10 other videos or a hundred other
videos.
And what of course transpired is a thousand video responses in a week,
more than 60,000 video responses,
uh,
currently more than 60 million views of those videos currently.
And some pretty influential people have taken control,
um,
from Obama to lady Gaga to popular culture and programming.
Like the office did a piece on it gets better as well.
And Dan had talked about how even other advocate groups had a real problem with
the fact that these guys were using social media to tell their story and reach
young kids.
And his point was,
um,
I embraced the ideals and the values of creating change,
but if modern technology and tools have evolved to allow me to reach more,
why would I not use them?
That's just,
those are rules,
but they're bad rules.
So let's change them.
He also talks passionately about what he calls making a doable difference in his
belief is,
and the world of advocacy.
Too many brands as consumers to do things that sounded like the impossible.
If only we could raise $1 billion if only we could collect this amount of blood.
If only we could take this amount of guns away and people feel powerless in that
conversation.
And his point was to unleash ideas and tools that made people feel that they
could participate and that they could have a hand.
His language was give people the opportunity to make a doable difference and as
a consequence it get,
it gets better.
It continues to grow.
We,
we talked to him about the notion of do you ever imagine a world where we won't
need an,
it gets better?
And he said,
no,
the form may change,
but the notion of hate seems like it will persist if we're always going to need
tools and the benefit of wisdom from adults who can say this is how you deal and
cope and his point of view on calling it gets better or brand is he's against
it.
He doesn't think the old confines and rules of branding and organizations are
what helps us succeed.
He thinks you need to set it free in the world.
So if chapter one was about taking leadership personally in chapter two is
around behaving your beliefs.
The third chapter is really about unleashing ideas in the world,
enrolling consumers as owners ideas.
And effectively I think the language we use is letting outsiders in.
So from that we branched into chapter four,
which talks about unconventionality,
um,
staying different.
Um,
the story that we want to share with you guys today,
it's about the Belmont stakes.
This is a brand that's 150 years old.
Um,
we've kind of like the original must see event in America.
It's the third race in the triple crown.
So it gets a lot of attention,
especially when there's a triple crown race up for grabs.
And well,
the,
one of the issues that the Belmont stakes and all of horse racing is facing is
the Porsche racing is kind of lost a generation of fans.
Um,
it's not nearly as popular as the NBA or the NFL.
There are a lot of sports that have drawn people away,
um,
for,
for a variety of different reasons.
So Chris k,
the re founder of the Belmont stakes,
which is a term we use for people who have come to takeover brands.
Um,
uh,
after they'd been around for awhile,
um,
had his hands full when he came onboard in 2014 looking at what can we do to get
people either to stick with the sport or to come back into this sport.
Um,
so we start the story in the book.
In 2014 with the racing of the,
the 2014 triple crown,
California chrome was up for grabs,
uh,
up for the triple crown,
didn't actually win.
And so the disappointment was magnified by the fact that 110,000 people were at
this event and couldn't basically get out.
The train stations were not set up for that kind of crowd.
Um,
the,
the roads were completely packed.
Um,
and Chris was in his first year running this event said something has to change.
So the following day,
um,
he did what a traditional brand manager would not do.
I think a traditional brand manager would look for ways to cut money out of the
system and sell tickets,
sell as many tickets as possible,
so maybe we can invest in,
you know,
more seating.
Um,
he decided we're going to sell fewer tickets next year and we're going to invest
in,
in making this a better experience for the people who come both who see it on
television as well as who come to the event.
So,
um,
of course things like HD cameras and HD televisions were deployed or all around
the stadium where the events held,
bringing the sport kind of up to the level that you see in the NFL and the NBA.
Um,
the experience was improved by,
I think they cut maybe 20,000,
something along that it's around 20,000 tickets out of the sales.
So far fewer people came and made it a more enjoyable experience for everybody
that was able to come to the,
to come to the race.
Um,
and really what he was looking to do,
it was looking outside his category.
So rather than stick to the conventions of horse racing and just copying what
the Kentucky Derby does,
for example,
he looked to what other major sports do what Vegas does.
Um,
look to entertainment.
one of his best ideas that I love is he brought in a concert.
I'm a list.
I'm banned.
I think the Goo goo dolls performed the very first time,
um,
right after the,
the next year is triple crown race.
That way people stuck around even after the race,
some,
some didn't actually get in their cars or hopping the trains and,
and create as much.
So it's just these little touches that really made the event that much better.
Um,
uh,
Bobby also notably,
he expanded it from a one day event to a three day event so they can move the
racists out,
um,
and have a better distribution.
So as you look at the Belmont stakes today,
it's,
it's far more modern,
far more appealing to modern sports consumers than it was even just five years
ago.
Um,
and so that,
that really is about the,
the,
the whole chapter talks about how you maintain that unconventional core that
keeps people interested in your brand.
So as we wander away into the fifth and final chapter of the book,
the fifth and final principle of the book we started really with,
it's all about a personal style or approach to leadership.
We move our way to organizations and rolling themselves in those beliefs where
brand leaders have to behave their beliefs and then organizations bringing
outsiders in and then behaving not with the orthodoxy but against the orthodoxy.
The fifth and final chapter is pivotal because it really talks about not just
doing things episodically but doing things perpetually.
Um,
Lucas began today's conversation with reference to Gibson Guitars and radio
shack and Brookstone and necco candy brands that at one point in time had done
something fascinating but got stuck doing the same thing.
Repetitiously over time it didn't evolve.
So instead of saying the values persist,
but the manifestations change,
they said the values persist in the manifestations persist as well and
ultimately become less relevant.
So the iconic story we'd like to tell here is Taylor guitars.
And as I shared at the outset,
I'm going to position a failed musician.
But nonetheless,
um,
I grew up having a reverence for Taylor guitars because it was a modern company
that sort of came out of nowhere that unseated a brand like Martin guitars,
which had been around for a very long time.
And the reason they've succeeded in their own words is because they always ask
themselves in 10 years,
in 10 years from now,
will we be happy that we make the choices that we made today?
And if the answer is that in 10 years they will be happier,
more successful,
more fulfilled.
They make choices and decisions and service of a 10 year outcome.
So if they have to change the way they distribute,
they do it.
They didn't buy into the distribution system in Europe.
They knocked it down.
They built their own distribution system.
They learned about hrs policies in Europe and they invested the time Monday to
do it because they felt that owning their own distribution channel would make a
difference if they didn't like the way materials were being manufactured in
their guitars.
They invested in factories in Cameroon and they got involved in fair work
practices and fair wages.
And so they weren't just making guitars.
They were impacting the way that guitars were being made from the outset.
And they have a lovely point of view that the way you carry ideas forward for
generations is you enroll the people who work with you as family and co owners
as well.
So I'll give you some examples that they shared with us.
When the economy went to bad,
rather than laying off a substantial portion of their workforce,
they cut everyone back to four days and they got the group together.
And instead of saying,
some of you keep your jobs and some of you lose your jobs,
they said,
we want everyone to continue to be a part of it,
so we're all going to work four days,
not five.
And what they did not tell their workforce is in the background.
They were keeping track of lost wages and the economy went back to good.
All those people who stayed with them through the four days got paid for that
fifth day in each one that they lost wages for before.
Um,
the other thing that they've subsequently done,
which for us was fascinating and we've got a lot of questions from the press
about it,
is in real time they're picking the successor of their brand today who's cross
training with the founder of the organization.
So what they'd observed is a lot of guitar companies and Gibsons,
a perfect example look to build in volume and take costs out of the system.
So if Gibson one started as the consequence or passion of someone who wants to
build beautiful guitars,
it became the output of a marketing organization that would distribute widely
and distribute cheaply.
And their point of view is eventually that system is going to run out of steam
because what made brands like fender and Gibson so special wasn't wide
distribution and cheap costs is that those brands actually had a story to tell
and values that they held dear.
And so their point of view is they're not going to sell to the highest bidder.
They're going to turn employees into co owners of the brand and they're going to
build their successor today.
So a guy named Andy powers,
uh,
was found after a long search.
He works with Bob Taylor.
They're designing guitars together today and it's in his contract effectively
that when Bob Taylor moves on,
Andy can't just reissue the old guitars that are made today.
He has to design and build new guitars in the spirit of what Taylor's always
about.
He has to bring the brand forward.
Contractually,
it's also his responsibility to find the next successor.
So Andy contractually,
you can't just come in one day and say,
I hate this place or I'm done with this place and I'll see you later in real
time.
Just as Bob Taylor has done,
he has to find a successor and train him or her and pass values and culture
forward.
And when you think about the brands that maybe you work with,
and I think about the brands that maybe we work with,
I can't tell you that,
that,
that that's a very common attitude in the slide is the vast majority of the
brands are concerned with today.
The vast majority of brands are concerned with quarterly reporting,
maximizing shareholder revenue.
It's the few,
not the many that think about growing cultures and values first and finding ways
to perpetuate it forward.
Um,
we often get a lot of heads nodding and people saying it sounds ideal and it
sounds beautiful.
Why is it that more brands are not behaving this way to which the answer is
because it's hard because when economy goes to bad,
you're inclined to save money,
make more money,
save money,
sell more product,
let go of staff to save on wages.
And these are companies that are doubling down on culture.
Lucas reminded me,
the Ritz Carlton actually had a lovely solution when the economy went to bad.
They ran a campaign that said to wealthy people,
the ones who retained their wealth ish.
Um,
if you can't take the vacation that you want this year,
you shouldn't go on vacation.
Don't just spend money because you think to,
you need to spend it.
Um,
don't go in fewer vacations.
to save and only to save.
They effectively said,
get your priorities right in life.
Think about the things that matter most where things matter most.
Spend more time and money there and where things matter least save your money,
invest your time elsewhere.
And those are brave things for brands to take a leadership point of view.
The most surprising fact of that story is of all the brands and the Marriott
portfolio,
the Ritz Carlton was the number one leading brand in the down years after
recession.
The brand that charged the most,
we're really a person could say,
I could get a room anywhere,
a bedroom,
anywhere,
a conference room,
anywhere I could sleep in any hotel.
I don't need to go there.
They got more revenue per available room night from customers because they held
tight to their values and they came out recession on top.
Um,
so I'll turn it over to Lucas to sort of sum up the stories.
we have another little piece at the end that we'll talk about quickly and very
happy to answer a questions.
It's a topic we're very passionate about and it's amazing that in the time we've
written the book,
as Lucas said,
necco bankruptcy,
radio shack,
bankruptcy,
bankruptcy in three years,
blockbuster down to basically finally near done.
It's not a proud moment to say what the costs of what's happening in the world
around us because what's happening around us isn't a wonderful thing.
Brands that we thought would be around forever disappearing.
Um,
but it's a special thing to have knowledge from the ones who found ways to
thrive.
So turn it over to Lucas to sum it up.
Yeah.
So that the beginning of the book process was really sitting down with all these
lessons,
all these stories,
and starting to say,
where are the common themes,
where the chapter breaks,
what,
what are,
what are the takeaways for this?
Um,
and what we started to see was something we've come to call the modern legacy
mindset.
And that's the,
the five core chapter ideas.
Um,
traditional band brand leaders will follow organizational principles,
institutional rules.
Um,
what we found modern legacy builders doing is following longterm personal
ambitions.
Um,
that's the first chapter.
A traditional rand leaders will lean into saying one thing,
doing another,
a lot of attitude,
a lot of posturing,
modern legacy builders really behave their beliefs and their values.
Uh,
the third chapter about letting outsiders in a traditional brand leaders
followup can command and control model.
Um,
I'll still love it.
This is a very difficult thing for modern brands to do.
Um,
but modern legacy brands step outside of that and let outsiders in and really
let consumers take a role in the brand and they build a lot of influence that
way.
Um,
the Fourth Chapter I talked about the Belmont stakes,
uh,
that's all about,
being unconventional.
Um,
traditional bullet brand leaders will stick to their category and follow the
Orthodox of,
of the business that they're in a modern legacy brands that are really willing
to break the category,
um,
via category of one and define their own category.
And the fifth chapter the mark just spoke about with Taylor guitars is about
being perpetual.
A lot of brand leaders will evolve episodically when they need to.
I'm repeating what they do well until it's absolutely necessary to completely
change.
Um,
and what we see is the brands like a Gibson Guitars,
toys r US blockbuster,
they wait too long.
It's a short term mindset and you wind up seeing them go bankrupt or out of
business.
Um,
brand leaders that are building modern legacies are evolving all the time to
constant process.
It's going to add one of the,
the questions we often get asked is it all sounds so ideal,
but that these companies make money as well.
The ones that you studied.
Uh,
the balance of not entirely all the brands in the bulk are brands that are
succeeding in not just cultural terms,
put financial terms,
I'll share a story and a half.
One is from a leader in the first chapter,
uh,
named Tony Co who launched a brand called Nick's cosmetics.
And she had a very strong point of view though it is a leader,
of course you want to leave with culture and values,
but you need to make money as well because money allows you to hire people,
grow,
pay healthcare,
who wants to work for a leader that tells you they don't want to make money.
So our,
our thinking philosophy is not do good and don't make money.
Our philosophy I think very much is do good and as a consequence other good
things will happen including making money.
Um,
the other piece that I wanted to share is,
um,
the foreword for the book is definitely worth reading.
Um,
we'll tell you how to get a copy of the book next week,
but if you haven't read the book and you just want to see a tease,
we can send you a link.
The Ford from the book is now online.
It was written by Yvon Chouinard is the founder of Patagonia and Yvonne,
um,
in the past year became famous once again,
he,
a famous guy,
um,
for posting on is for,
for sale websites,
commercial website,
uh,
the Patagonia brand that the president just sold your land.
And so you could agree with his politics or not.
We're not taking a stand on that.
Um,
but what we will take a stand on is he's a guy that put his values out front.
He said,
my brand believes in nature and park lands and the ability to enjoy them today
and for generations to come.
And I perceive the government is threatening what my brand holds dear.
And so right up in his home page,
he said,
the president stole your land.
As it turns out,
in that same year,
it was the most profitable year that Patagonia has ever had.
So for the ones who questioned the value of,
um,
good ethics and high ideals and longterm ambition,
he,
he is proof positive that you can do it at a very high level of being very
successful as well.
Um,
the last thing that I'll leave you with before we sort of opened up if there
happened to be questions is we often get asked,
uh,
by folks how can they get involved in some of the work that we're doing.
We never started out with the ambition of a for profit business,
but we've been approached about helping people with branding.
So we do that gladly.
Um,
we didn't begin with the idea that we were going to write a book.
We began researching and earnest,
as I said,
obviously about to become a dad and I want to learn from people that I admired.
Um,
and yet it became such an interesting topic that every time we spoke to a leader
or they'd refer us to a friend,
they'd asked for a transcript because they never told the story before.
Um,
and so here are ways that you can get involved.
If you have a story that you think is worth covering,
um,
please share it with us.
The book has brands that are a hundred years and older and as brands that are 10
years and younger,
it has brands that are 40 years old.
Our philosophy is legacy is something that you would write every day cause
you're either running it every day or do you become a part of ancient history?
People read what you want's to.
So if you know someone,
please share it with us.
If you happen to have a story,
this is your personal story,
your work here or a side hustle.
Um,
share it with us.
We're interested in that.
The other thing that we've done is we've created a foundation.
Um,
so our commitment was yet again,
because we weren't doing this strictly to make money or are initially ever to
make money,
was that anytime something good happened,
we'd reinvest it in people who live and work this way.
So,
uh,
two years ago we ran a program called legacy honors.
I'm David Remnick from the New Yorker was a recipient as a refound or of the
year and before he collaborated or bulky,
Vaughn was a founder of the year,
um,
and they got bursaries that they passed forward to businesses that they felt
should persist for a long time.
So He von gave $10,000 to Doctors Without Borders because he felt that
healthcare is a basic human right.
And if you're an adventure,
you may need healthcare at some point.
And David gave his to the committee to protect journalism because he felt in the
environment that we operate in journalists,
we're not getting the fair do.
And they were putting their lives on the line and he passed $10,000 forward to
them.
Next week on the 28th of the month,
almost right around the corner at our agency called team won,
uh,
with inc magazine.
We're announcing the first ever young,
effectively young legacy makers,
the ones who don't have fully formed and established businesses,
but who are making active change to the way culture and society work and behave.
Today,
there are five recipients.
Um,
they're too young activists who are 11 years old who'd been in the news a fair
amount recently.
They're two slightly older but still young activists who've gotten notoriety,
um,
on a Forbes list.
Um,
and there's a young interesting filmmaker who's gotten notoriety at the Sundance
Film Festival.
Um,
we're passing forward grants to them as well.
So if you're curious to come here more,
either more about the book and we're giving away free copies of the book if
you'd like that evening,
um,
or to hear the stories about the young legacy makers,
we'd love to have you or your colleagues and peers come and join us.
And with that on behalf of Lucas and me,
um,
I just want to say thank you for giving us some of your time today and joining
us.
You
have some time for questions.
F You have a question?
I will toss this in your direction and pass on the microphone.
You want to catch it?
The microphone?
No,
this is good.
This is the micro.
Yes.
I have like three questions,
but I'll [inaudible] I'll ease into them and give other people a chance.
And it was really interesting talk.
Um,
I'm,
I'm wondering how much the advancement of technology,
um,
and you know,
the Internet and how much,
uh,
that has made things move much more quickly,
has,
um,
impacted maybe the newer brands that are trying to establish in terms of,
uh,
their ethics and morals.
Um,
because if they're not ethical then and people discover that then it becomes
like a wildfire on the Internet to say like,
this is the,
you know,
the unscrupulous way in which this brand is doing business and that can cause
them to fail a lot faster.
Can you,
can you talk about that a little bit?
Yeah,
I see that mark and speak a little bit more on the client side,
but I can say that,
um,
right out of the gate we add an assumption.
When we published this book and started doing the work that we were doing,
that the types of brands that would approach us would be the long standing
brands,
the brands that were in trouble of going out of business and wanting to preserve
their legacy.
Um,
what we found is actually there's the majority of the brands that approaches are
the younger brands,
the newer brands.
Um,
and sometimes brands that are,
are,
uh,
very popular.
They've got some great product but haven't spent the time to say,
what are we about?
Like what,
what do we do?
You can actually share that if you want to show that the tech story that's
probably relevant to the story.
The,
uh,
the front of the first chapter is over your thing.
I'm thinking about the,
the consulting,
uh,
prior to the book.
So there was a company that may or may not be in this neck of the woods,
um,
that,
uh,
likely works in the tech space that came with an interesting proposition,
which was they could tell us what they were building that night.
Um,
but they had a hard time thinking about what they were building in the future.
And it became particularly relevant for them because as they were looking to
mature as an organization,
that investors who were asking hard questions of them,
which is in a sea of companies that are popping up overnight with interesting
things,
why is yours worth backing?
And they're honest assessment of it was they did not know how to answer that
question.
Um,
and that became incredibly important.
And that's fairly common,
which is we see plenty of people who are walking in the agency.
You say,
my goal is I'm going to start a company,
sell it for $1 billion as fast as I can,
and then I'm done.
And our endeavors actually to say our thinking is not for those people are
thinking is not for everyone.
Um,
technology is changing.
Things are moving at a fast pace,
but it's not permission to not have a longterm ambition or a goal.
So the ones who define their businesses only by the hardware or the ones who are
most likely to be copied and imitated quickly at a lower price.
And the ones who say the hardware is simply a manifestation of a larger idea or
the ones who have an opportunity to last for a longer period of time.
The other story that I'll add very quickly is that the start of our first
chapter,
start a baller chapters.
We would rip the stories that a culture,
so the vast majority of stories that we covered or based on primary research,
but the front of every chapter,
you find what was supposed to be an iconic leader,
that everyone in the world would agree is making the kind of positive change
that it eases you into a chapter.
So right at the start of chapter one is Mark Zuckerberg from Facebook and we
wrote about him before.
Of course,
the questions came out about um,
transparency and data.
Um,
and so we've subsequently been asked questions about the degree to which we
stand behind the story and we,
we have the same answer and we feel strongly about it,
which is we didn't write the history book on brands that forever more doing
exceptional things.
We covered a moment in time where leaders and brands were doing exemplary work
and if they want to be in the next book,
they would continue to hold fast to the values that got them there.
And if they abandon them,
they liked,
they wouldn't be in the,
in the next book.
So we actually found it not,
um,
it was a fascinating thing,
which is it forced us in the readers of the book and the press is bell to
confront the reality that we weren't talking about people who should be famous
for what they once did.
We're talking about people who live by their words every single day and help to
write history every day.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
In a similar vein,
you talked about blockbuster and radio shack who,
yeah,
their business model kind of went away.
Uh,
but there's a lot of theories about how they could have pivoted or
recontextualized to still exist.
So are there examples of companies that kind of maintain their legacy and values
while having to change what they did pretty fundamentally?
It's interesting you say that,
that the,
the story that we also put in the book in the very beginning is Kodak too.
We would kind of bunched those three together as cautionary tales.
And I love the Codec version as a cautionary tale because they actually invented
the digital camera back in like 1974 and somebody brought it to an executive and
the executive said this would ruin our photo business.
We've,
we have printing booths everywhere.
That's all our revenue.
Like this is not something that we want to put out there.
So they,
they buried the invention and ultimately it was their demise.
Um,
so it's a,
it's a fascinating little case study.
Um,
as far as,
um,
brands that have transitioned.
What I do think is interesting is some of the brands in the book will come to us
and say,
the honest company is a good example there,
right here,
right around the corner.
They'll tell you,
we build these products.
You know,
we're,
we,
we sell these products.
Um,
but tomorrow we could be selling something entirely different because it's the
values and our mission,
um,
aren't necessarily about the products.
Um,
the honest company for example,
is about a cleaner,
greener world.
Um,
they could be be making clothing next year.
It would still stay true to that principle.
They would just be doing that in a different industry.
I've been surprised by how many times we've heard that.
Um,
but you can you think of examples or a
Ritz Carlton's another reasonable one,
which is in response to the question in a hundred years from now,
what do you hope persist?
One of the founding members was very reflective and he said,
if the hotels look the same and if people dressed the same,
and if people act in exactly the same way that people fundamentally
misunderstand what this brand is all about.
We're about ladies and gentlemen,
Treating People as ladies and gentlemen,
we're about graciousness and manners and a world that is often without them.
And to a degree,
we're about creating memories that last a lifetime.
So it's not just about a two or three nights day,
it's about us a seven memory stay for example.
And his point was we teach culture and value every day.
And that's why today we have hotels and tomorrow we're going to have yachts and
beyond that,
um,
the Ritz Carlton might manifest as something fundamentally different than a
conventional hotel company.
They've got an interesting phone call from I'm a documentarian,
uh,
group is making a documentary and they said,
we're going to cover airbnb and we're going to cover the Ritz Carlton is
examples of,
um,
iconic,
successful hospitality spaces today.
And their question was,
which hotels do you want us to document?
And the Ritz Carlton said,
um,
uh,
effectively we don't care.
And they said,
what?
W what do you mean?
Which are the hotels you want to show off?
And they said any of them and none of them,
because what defines us that are not the walls will tell you the people that
we'd like you to document it because we think the people in the style of service
is the thing that lives on.
And it took the media company while to digest it,
but when they understood,
they said,
yeah,
I guess that what,
that's what makes you an airbnb fundamentally different ones about the spaces
that you occupy.
And one's about the heath interactions you have to no matter where you go.
And they said yes,
that's what we hope lives for a hundred years.
Those human interactions.
Um,
so over time we'll look to plus those stories.
But I think honest is one in the making.
I think Ritz is a brand that's um,
more than 30 years old.
It's probably not a bad one.
And um,
it'd be curious to see what happens with brands like bluebird over time.
Um,
there were fascinating story.
They refuse to knock down the walls and make it a venue for thousands of people.
They say that if the performers can't see the audience,
the experience dies and yet they're looking for ways to transport that
experience all over the world that doesn't violate their culture and values.
Somebody a curious,
one
question about legacy when it comes to um,
industries making significant shifts.
So like you guys are from [inaudible] automotive industry is working to be like
more mobility focused instead of selling cars.
And like that's a,
that's a hard,
right?
Right.
Like that's not like a,
Oh,
let's think about this.
They're trying to do it really quickly.
Um,
what's your guys' take on legacy when there's companies that are trying to take
on things that might be outside of their zone?
Mm,
well,
I can speak to automotive directly,
which is,
um,
that world is changing so dramatically that I believe if you sat down with Akio
Toyoda,
he would tell you mobility,
um,
isn't a made up idea that he would take,
mobility was always a part of the DNA.
Maybe it was not at the top of the pyramid.
Maybe it wasn't always discussing revealed,
but he would tell you the way they move people through the world,
including how they move people through a dealership,
how they move people through an online experience,
how they move people from home to work and be on.
He would tell you it's a part of the truth of the company.
One of the supporters of our book that we're quite proud of is Simon Sinek and
when Simon got involved,
he was skeptical at first.
He said,
I'm sure you're talking to a lot of people who are telling you fairytales and
fantasies about what they wished they would become,
but don't represent the truth of what they are.
And once we started dissecting the stories and going through them,
he,
he became a fan,
particularly of the fast company story.
Um,
and I think he particularly like the Taylor story,
but he really challenged us as you're,
you're appropriately doing,
which is to say,
or do you guys just showing the shiny pieces that companies want you to see or
these real elements of the brand?
So for automotive specifically,
I think Toyota has some truth in the notion of mobility and what they look like
tomorrow.
Better be fundamentally different than today because otherwise there'll be dead
and gone.
Yeah,
totally.
I just,
I look at Mark Fields and what they were doing with Ford and it's like,
you know,
the FordPass totally tanked,
right?
And it's like,
how,
how are you going to do this the right way?
And it is,
it's a,
it's a big change,
right?
So the,
you're right about the DNA of [inaudible].
It always being about mobility,
but it's like,
how do you do it the right way and how do you buy yourself enough time?
Uh,
which is another key piece of it.
Like when you're talking about switching from going from selling cars or
whatever it may be,
to whatever shift you're doing as a company,
like how much of a period of time do you need to change,
even if it is part of your legacy change to the dynamics of your business?
I'll shut up now
we write it.
We wrote a piece in the book,
it right to the end that talks about the old measurement system was a simple
evaluation of assets and liabilities.
So in a quarter or a year,
what are the things that hold value?
What are the things that are losing value?
And we've worked with a semiotician in London and built a model,
which is concurrently looking at latent value.
Those things that still have value,
but if you don't evolve,
it becomes useless.
And concurrently looking at the things that you change in real time.
Because if you're not looking at head and creating things that don't exist,
you're going to find out that your Alexis is unseated by Tesla and blockbusters
unseated by Netflix because they never bothered to pay attention.
And Ritz Carlton could be unseeded by Airbnb because they were late to the
timeshare game.
Yeah.
So we do think it's a fundamental shift.
On the one hand,
the,
the idea that,
um,
repeat the past,
if I just do that,
I can't fail many understand that even if it fails,
who could say that I was wrong for doing what one sport?
Equally,
we see the ones who say,
screw the past the pastors in the past.
I'm here for my three year tenure as a CMO or CEO.
It's a whole new future.
I'm going to make my mark,
build my resume,
move on.
The hardest things to actually reconcile the two.
What are the pieces of the passport thing con to and what are those elements in
my dirty that we better add or we're going to fail?
Yeah.
So I think we have good examples of brands in the making,
and I think this is going to be a constant work in progress.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Appreciate your time.